can we use grass fed liver instead of B vitamins? Well, grass fed liver has
benefits so I think good, clean, organ meat has a lot of benefits for us. So yes,
I think it is. How many B vitamins are in it? I don't, I'm not sure. I don't know if you're
getting, if you're eating grass fed liver just the liver itself, is that going to
contain enough B vitamins. I don't, I don't know either. And if you're, if you're
just getting B vitamins because you feel like you should be getting B vitamins,
or you're getting, you're taking B vitamins because a measure deficiency, then
you just read, if you're measuring something, okay, let's say you're measuring
homocysteine. And I don't want to be taking methyl Ds or anything. I just want to
grass fed liver. Well, then go ahead and try that and measure the homocysteine again. So if you're
doing it because you're trying to do something that's good for you, that's not something you're measuring,
that, then you just have to try it.